bonsoir matière kate tout d'abord je
suis tellement heureuse d'être là ce
soir a dégoté une fois pas très souvent
tu vis en angleterre c'est déjà plus
près que l'australie les une grande
voyageuse tu vas d'appeler à l'autre
aujourd'hui en france hier en espagne
mais s'il ya un continent que tu explore
inlassablement
c'est celui du cinéma
tulle habite avec une telle constance et
une telle curiosité que c'est même plus
un continent c'est une planète
tu habites la planète cinéma tu donner
ni locataire ni propriétaire beaucoup
trop libre pour ça car ta liberté
justement c'est ce qui te raconte le
mieux cette liberté te permet toutes les
audaces s'immisce dans chaque rôle que
tu incarnes tu peux tout jouer même un
homme même un serpent tu nous donnes
envie de devenir ces personnages que tu
interprètes tu nous tu nous inspire ce
désir de liberté tout alors j'aurais
voulu ce soir de faire l'héroïne d'une
pièce de théâtre ou d'un roman mais nous
sommes à la télévision donc je dois te
raconter en quelques minutes
à toi seul tu peux plus de planètes donc
bon ça va j'ai déjà planté le décor je
pourrais m'arrêter là c'est déjà pas mal
mais je vais pas te laisser seuls sur
cette planète rennes solitaire en son
royaume telle qu'on a découverte pour la
première fois
alors devrais je parlais de toutes les
autres multiples qui sont en toi qui tu
habites
ça fait du monde bien devrais je parlais
de ton visage de tes cheveux de dépôt
mètres de ta façon de parler de t'avoir
de ton et de ta bouche de ton sourire de
ton énergie de ta folie de ta force de
sa vitalité
on met presse
je dois faire un choix
alors je vais donc parler
de tes yeux
un miroir
de lac aux eaux polaires tropicale
rieurs triste candide intelligent naïf
insondable énigmatique moqueur curieux
rêveur tragique sauvage oui sauvage
humains terriblement humain mais sauvage
comme l'habitante de cette planète
des yeux bleus magnifiques
dont regards de cinéma qui nous enchante
dans tous les films que tu traverses et
reste avec nous bien au delà du
générique de fin
alors ce soit nous avons l'immense joie
de croiser ce regard et moi de te dire
les yeux dans les yeux
toute mon admiration toute mon affection
et mon immense joie de te remettre
ce césar d'honneur pour célébrer la
liberté ton audace tout ce qui
caractérise son extraordinaire carrière
comme tous ici j'en attends impatiemment
la suite mesdames et messieurs kate
blanchett
[Applaudissements]